Nice to meet you!
Wow!
All of the people here are barringals.
Please use honorifics.
Yes!
I'm speaking Japanese!
I'm a genius!
Cassette tape?
How do I get myself ready?
You can put it in here.
I don't know.
I was like, you're not ready.
And I was like, uh...
Me too!
How do you get ready?
Eyelashes are on fleek, man.
I don't know.
How do you get ready?
How do you do that?
This was in tutorial, man.
This was in tutorial.
This was five minutes ago.
How do you surrender?
Oh, I surrender too!
We all surrender.
You are the commander of the barrage.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you for coming today.
Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
So, today, we are going to have a bilingual Japanese, English, and Chinese conversation.
That's cool, man.
Someone died.
So, you guys are welcome to speak English, Japanese, whatever language is comfortable for you guys.
Stop dying!
Can we have introductions so that we know which color is which?
Which color is who?
Yeah.
Wait, how do you guys point?
We can hear you!
I don't want people to stare.
You can change the mic with the mouse.
Oh, really?
That's amazing.
You can toggle the mic.
Where is Henya?
I can't hear her voice.
She's gone.
I can hear her.
I can see her talking on Discord.
Huh?
Is she talking?
Henya, you don't have a voice in the game, right?
Henya, I'm not lying.
I was in the game, so I couldn't hear you.
I can't hear you.
I can't hear you, Henya.
I can hear you.
No, no, no, no, Henya.
I hear you, Geary.
Everyone's getting ready.
It's the first time for everyone, so it's fun, right?
Let's start with...
The light blue one?
Hi.
Nice to meet you.
Good morning.
I am...
Did you hide that much?
That's how you talk, right?
I am Mint Phantom.
Nice to meet you.
Why are you laughing?
Nice to meet you!
Mint!
Yeah, I'm Mint.
Nice to meet you guys.
Nice to meet you.
John Dongri.
You're lying!
John Dongri?
Who?
Who is John Dongri?
Who is it?
Henya, I still can't hear you.
I don't think... I think she left.
Are you okay?
Who is it?
It's true!
Who are you?
Who is it?
Okay, let's go.
I don't know at all.
Isn't it someone you don't know?
Who is it?
I don't know.
We have an imposter.
A real imposter.
At least you find Hideya-senpai because I don't... I'm
not...
Oops.
Sorry.
I'll permit the actual imposter.
Bro, I was just looking around and I was like, Who the hell is doing this control now?
I think I forgot to set it as private.
I'm sorry.
I don't even know if there's private for this customer lobby.
Oh, wait.
I'll switch my color.
Can I be green?
You can do pink, I think.
No, Kacen's pink.
Pink is Kacen-senpai, okay?
Okay.
Yes.
Hello.
Oh, you're orange.
Welcome to No Limit.
To No Limit?
Wait.
Oh.
Take your time, baby.
How do you point?
With right click.
Do it.
Yeah.
It's silent.
I think I changed.
Am I yellow now?
Yeah, you yellow.
Yeah.
Kacen-senpai.
Yeah, you yellow.
Can you be orange?
He's killing me.
Can you say something?
Okay, I can change color.
I can change color.
Thank you very much.
Oh,
Henya is strictly in the Discord.
Henya is not actually in the game itself.
Her voice.
Can you unmute on Discord and put everyone's volume on zero?
Yes.
I think I finally got it.
Henya-senpai, that's gonna happen.
No, no, no, no.
That's gonna happen.
I think I finally got it, but...
So, everyone, put your volume on zero so the poopy show moves.
Oh, okay.
I trust you with that.
So, I'll set everyone to zero.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Okay.
Damn it, Hestia.
Every time I change a color, you change it to the exact color.
I was yellow, and then you were yellow.
I was like, okay, you know what, girl?
I'm gonna change it to a different color.
I'm gonna change blue.
I look over.
Guess who's blue.
Okay, I'm gonna change it again.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me change it.
No, no, no, let me change it.
I'm gonna change it to dark blue.
I am now going to be dark blue.
Dark blue.
That's not gonna happen.
Wait, why?
I'm gonna be dark blue.
You're white.
I agree.
Wait, how are you guys the same?
What the hell is going on?
Why am I synchronized with you?
We're both white.
Why are we white?
Hestia, I swear, don't put me here, girl.
Don't put me here.
I swear, I did not threaten you guys.
And I was like, no.
Let me change it to dark blue.
And then you were like, no.
And change it to white.
We can figure this out.
Okay, wait.
Who's this?
Okay, I'm purple now.
No, I'm gonna be purple.
It's too...
Okay, okay, we are different.
Okay, okay, we are different now.
Okay, take what you got.
Okay, we are all unique colors.
Okay.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm dark.
What the fuck?
Ah!
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Ah, ah...
What is this?
Fuck it, I'm gonna go with this one.
Wait,
is her mic plugged into the game?
I'm gonna...
Wait, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna make myself...
Oh my god.
We will have to underline.
Now I look like a LeBron James.
My pookie LeBron Pon.
I said it to the tax person.
Fuck!
What is she talking about?
She's talking about the tax payers.
What the fuck?
We only did two people.
My name is RPR...
Done.
Let's go next.
I'm red.
Let's do it again.
Let's go.
Me?
Hello, nice to meet you!
My name is Kison!
Nice to meet you!
Yay!
Me?
Oh!
Hello, it is I.
Yay!
It was her moment!
RPR, you shut up!
Yuri, one more time.
One more time?
Oh.
Hello, it is I, Yuri.
I cook stuff.
Hello.
Yay!
It's me, RPR.
I eat stuff.
Yay!
Oh, me?
Hello, I'm Maxwell.
Nice to meet you.
Hello, I'm Axel.
Nice to meet you!
Okay, next!
Oh, it's Genius!
Nice to meet you!
Yay!
Hello,
my name is RTK.
Some people call me Charlie.
I make stuff.
Nice to meet you!
Charlie!
How do I ready?
Let me set ready.
Mint!
Mint-san!
Nice to meet you.
I'm Mint Phantom.
Yay!
Oh!
What is this color?
White?
It's me.
Nice to meet you.
How do you ready?
Cue.
Cue and ready.
Cue and then set ready.
Yay!
He really died!
I see
What is that?
I thought it was obvious.
I think I played it before.
Yeah, I think we will find out.
Yeah, maybe.
I think so.
Yeah.
Oh!
Yeah!
Guys, I've never played this game before and I also didn't do the tutorial.
I'm innocent!
Scanner?
Where is the scanner?
Enya, have you played this game before?
No.
Me too.
I haven't even played the tutorial.
Me too!
Are you an imposter?
No, I'm an employee.
Me too!
Are you an imposter?
No, I'm an employee.
Are you sure?
Yeah, I'm real, real, real.
No, no!
Real, real, real, real, real!
No, no, no!
Press F.
F?
No,
no, no!
It is the first time!
First time!
Put your hands up.
High touch.
What are you pointing at?
I didn't shower today, sorry.
Oh, there is a timer!
Oh my gosh, we have 7 minutes.
6 minutes.
Ok...
I don't know!
I have...
I have scanner delivery pressure.
What is that sound?
I don't know.
Scary!
What
is it?
Why am I dying?
Oh no!
What happened to you?
Yeah, we are both orbs!
We are both orbs!
Me too.
They are gonna start blaming each other.
Oh my gosh!
I don't know!
What happened?
Oh!
RPR!
Oh no!
No stamina?
Wait, you can die from running?
Stamina kills you if you use it too much.
We just...
What is it?
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Imposter too?
Yeah, looks like it maybe.
Oh my gosh!
Go!
I think we lost.
What happened?
Was it RPR?
It was RPR.
He literally was like, what's up guys?
And then he just shanked me.
It was definitely him.
My favorite is Axel was telling me, come to the hallway, someone died here.
And I just stabbed him in the back.
Literally, I looked back and he had a fucking knife on me.
I was trying to teach you how to play this game.
And I thought you were a helpless young kid.
And then you stabbed me in the booty hole.
Henry and I died from running too much.
You can die from running too much apparently.
Yeah, that's how Henry and I died.
Yeah, it was a test.
It was a test run.
Even if the bad guys are dead, right?
It wouldn't notify us.
So we have to always like...
Oh, so you have to kill them.
You can't just like boot them.
Yes.
What should we do with this?
Ready.
High touch!
Hi-five!
Hi-touch!
High touch!
Now it just looks like we're summiting.
Nah, you keep your hands to yourself.
Hey, I'll just give you a high five.
I don't want a high five either.
High five!
How did you get the map?
There's a map?
So basically, Giri is very good at explaining, so I'm going to leave it to Giri.
I like the what the GamGam that doesn't play games is the one that's explaining.
Okay, so for the map, when you're in the game, you press Q, you look at the map.
So generally, as soon as you open it, you'll see a list of things.
It can be like, Scan 1, Deliver 6, and Battery 3.
That was kind of what we had last time.
So if you hover over the individual quests or the individual tasks that you have to do, it'll highlight where the dots are for you to go to do that specific thing.
So generally, all of these tasks are color-coordinated.
So for scanning and stuff, if you're colorblind, then just follow the diagram.
If you're not colorblind, then just follow the colors because everything is color-coded.
Delivery, I would say, is the easiest quest to do because you go to the delivery section, which is the orange part of the map, and then you go grab boxes.
The boxes will have stickers that will match the different departments that you could deliver the boxes to.
For example, if you deliver a box to the green room, it'll have a leaf on it.
So take the box to the green room.
There's going to be flashing dots in the green room to tell you where to drop the boxes.
Drop the boxes.
That's going to be one out of six deliveries completed.
And then you just run back to court to do that stuff.
Did you make this game or...?
He called you a nerd!
We got this.
Axel, how does this look?
Do it again.
No,
no, no, no!
Oh no!
No, I want to Jork it.
How are you so good at that?
Oh, you're doing it!
You're doing it!
Axel is too busy Jorking it to get ready.
Ready out!
Kitty,
I'm gonna stick with you.
I don't know what to do.
OK!
And Gidi, hypothetically, hypothetically...
If I were an imposter, how would I kill someone?
Hypothetically.
Here, let's say...
No!
No, no!
Wait, no, no!
I said hypothetically.
I just tried to learn the game.
OK, I'm gonna find a knife.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just took some.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Top secret information.
Sorry.
OK, thank you.
Wait,
how do I reload?
How do I reload?
I don't have a knife.
I have a gun.
I think it's too easy being an imposter.
It's so true.
Yeah, I don't know.
Wait, is this ammo right here?
This little blue thing?
What is this?
I don't know what that is.
No, maybe not.
I think it's a plug.
I don't know actually.
I'm gonna go kill more people.
Oh, it's a fuse.
Gidi died to old age.
Sorry Gidi.
No ammo.
OK, I can use my hands.
I can use my hands.
I prefer it that way.
Sorry Gidson!
Oh sorry.
That's me!
What's that?
No, don't shoot!
I tried to kill K-san.
But I failed.
Look what she threw.
Yeah, I was the bad guy.
I'm sorry.
You didn't die by my hands.
You died of old age Gidi.
Everything kills you in this game.
You can't run, you can't jump.
You were also a bad guy or you were just an accomplice?
No, I was just a bad guy.
Oh, so there are two bad guys.
Wait,
so then they win?
Yeah.
But it looks like it's very easy to be the bad guy since you can die from exhaustion.
I think it's quite easy for bad guys to win.
I think so too.
That's what I said earlier.
There's 2 minutes and 40 seconds and if they don't make it, we win anyway?
Even though we're dead?
Oh, okay.
Easy.
Yeah, it's like Among Us.
If you don't finish the task, the bad guys win anyway.
What are you eating?
I'm eating noodles.
Yummy.
I got some Chinese takeout.
I'm so sorry guys, if you can hear, there's like leaf blowers outside.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry guys.
Oh, this is the gun room.
I should have gone here.
That's where they got the guns.
Look at that one on the top there.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I mean for you Mint, maybe you don't remember that.
Just stick with your batteries, okay?
Okay, okay.
I'll stick with my batteries.
I liked using it in my hands.
I like using it.
It felt more personal.
You like to feel the life of running, what is it called?
Flowing through your fingertips.
Yeah.
You like it when they slowly choke out and then just like the last breath between your hands.
I think you're speaking from experience right now.
No, no, no.
Me?
No.
I'm just, I just read doujin, you know.
That's what I do.
Oh, so true.
I like how the people that are left doing the task are the people who have no idea what's happening.
I don't know.
I thought K-Sun knew what she was doing because she felt so confident.
She did the, she did the computer.
I don't know if Hestia...
I don't know which scan Hestia is doing because scanner needs two people.
The one that K-Sun was doing, one person is fine.
Where's Tenya?
Is she dead too?
I don't know.
I'm gonna explore.
I've never looked...
Yeah.
Let's see.
There's pizza.
Let's go towards pizza.
Tenya?
I'm gonna do an actual task next time, you guys.
Oh, I think I heard her.
Why are they trying to kill people?
We're both dead.
I don't think they care.
They're just gonna die now.
Yeah, again I would.
I'm for sure, guys.
Never fuck RQR and never fuck Mint.
No, no, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
No, no, I'm good, I'm good.
I don't know what I look like, but you can trust me.
You can see here.
This is what you look like right here in this game viewer.
Wow, my eyes are so...
Is there a different map?
Has anyone actually won?
No, I'm an employee.
I'm professional, I'll do it.
We can win.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK,
yeah, delivery is easier.
There is a tutorial.
There is a tutorial when you open the map.
I think scanning...
Alright, I'm watching tutorial.
I'll play that next time.
We're learning, we're learning.
I'm an employee!
I'm scared, you guys.
Employee!
I'm just gonna get a gun just in case though.
No!
You can't use them.
What's my tasks?
Delivery.
Power.
So where am I?
Oh I'm there.
Let's go here.
OK guys, I'm gonna actually play the game.
So what do I do?
This?
Can I take the knife?
Oh I can.
Can I like... Oh!
Wait, how do I...
OK, so I can take the knife, but then I have something empty.
My bag is empty.
How do I put something in my bag?
I gotta find a fuse.
OK.
Toggle.
Thank you.
This is why I stream.
So you guys can help me.
A fuse.
There were fuses in...over here.
Empty!
It's empty!
You can't do that!
Watch out!
Mito-san!
That was dangerous!
It can't be helped.
It's this one, right?
I finally decided.
I thought it was this one.
It's fine.
There is nothing here.
I confirmed it.
Yes, yes, yes.
OK.
I don't have it.
OK, OK.
He's not holding it.
I don't have it.
OK, OK, OK.
I will do this.
How do I get in?
Oh, I got it!
OK, OK, OK.
And then this?
Wait, do I put this in there?
Oh...
Wait, how do I do this?
I feel like a monkey.
Wrong color?
But there is nothing in the bookie room.
I trusted.
I trusted him.
Oteki-san.
I just met him, but I trusted him.
I was doing the task.
He even told me how to do it.
Poor guy, he even murdered me.
Poor guy!
Poor...where is he?
What?
Hina-senpai?
Hina-senpai!
You are a monkey!
Where is he?
Where is the red dot on him?
Oteki-san!
Also, red dot means impostor guy.
Red dot.
They are doing their job.
Gidi is so diligent.
She does her job.
I think only impostors see red dots.
Yeah, I think so too.
Here, Hina in addition.
The way you unlock the guns car.
I'm watching and learning.
I don't get it.
That means you have to get the right number.
So...
Why is Mint-san dead?
Oteki-san.
Oteki-san was killed.
Oteki-san!
Why is Tetsuya-chan dead?
He was killed by Hina-senpai.
That's a lie!
He was alive!
Isn't that Kei-san?
He was killed by Kei-san-senpai.
Eh?
That's a lie!
Because he was shot...
Because he was shot, of course I would say it's a lie.
It's a revenge.
I'm scared.
That delivery was good.
This is the delivery.
Delivery.
There's so much here.
I don't know.
There's computers.
I think there's too many.
There's a lot.
It's a lot.
I feel like...this is like a...you know...
In your first day on a part-time job the boss will show you around what to do.
It feels like that.
Yes, it does.
Right?
Except we died.
It's your job.
True!
Can't believe we're dead.
We don't know anything.
We keep dying.
Me too.
Have you played Tutorial?
No.
My goodness, me too.
I believe that you are a kid.
I didn't play Tutorial, but I believe that you are a kid.
I can't believe you.
What?
No, it's OK.
I'm an employee.
What did we do wrong?
I thought we were doing everything so good.
Just how I feel about that.
No way!
OK,
are you guys ready to kill more?
Alright.
I'm kind of winning my task.
Yay!
We win!
My name will be there.
What happened?
I'm an employee.
OK guys, we got this this time.
I'll do it this time.
Scanner?
Scanner.
This way.
We'll live.
We'll play.
For real.
Scanner.
I hardly even know her.
Oh, OK.
Super good job.
No, I don't see anything.
Oh, I see.
You know how I'm looking right?
It goes right.
I'm looking left.
So you have to direct my head in a way to get to the circle and we have to do all that.
OK, so that's for you and Tenya now.
OK?
OK, I'll stand.
OK.
A
little more right.
A little bit.
A little right.
Just a little right.
A little bit.
What?
I'm sorry!
It can't be helped.
What is this?
What did it do?
What?
Kahoot?
I don't know.
We got one die.
Wait, Tenya was impostor.
Well, for Tenya it's OK.
We can look around you guys.
I don't know why anything is happening.
I want to go to the pizza room.
Oh, it's this way.
Pizza.
Oh, here.
Pizza room.
Oh, Pizushi.
Pizushi.
Seaweed?
I wish I could do stuff as a ghost.
Need rice.
Shouganai, she said.
I don't think she was impostor.
She said it can't be helped.
I don't know.
I actually don't know.
We haven't been down here, have we?
Guys, I'm still waking up.
It's hard to think.
I'm so tired.
I have my glasses on because I'm too tired to put in my contacts.
Are you guys doing OK?
Are you guys having fun watching my first time?
I've seen people play this game before, but I never...
So I knew it was kind of like Among Us style, but I've never played it myself.
This is my first time.
It's 9pm for you?
Wow.
It will be that time for me later.
You're learning too?
I'm nervous because it's my first time playing with everybody.
Well, not for everybody, but you know what I mean.
I don't know so many people here.
I got murdered by K-san.
Maybe that is, in of itself, an achievement.
What's this doing here?
Where is everybody?
Oh, that's a wall.
Dreams come true.
Wow, it's so peaceful.
Where is everybody actually?
Hello?
Wake up, wake up, wake up.
I think I'll take...oh wait.
I think they said that...
The collab should be about 2 hours, so I'm gonna do...
Nintendo Direct watch along after this.
What happened?
What the heck?
We got one die on the scan.
We did it!
And I trusted you!
Sorry!
OK!
High five!
Let's see...
Seriously?
Only you can do that.
Can we have like less tasks?
Yeah, less tasks.
Beginner recommended.
If you are not yet familiar with the game, reduce task complexity.
Less tasks.
Onegaishimasu.
There's only two!
Pressure.
Pressure, pressure.
I don't think delivery is a task.
No!
No, we only got one task though.
One task?
OK.
Yeah, we only got the pressure one.
Pressure.
What do you do for pressure?
What do I do here?
You need to bring the...what's it called?
The cans over here.
OK.
Oh, these ones.
Razzies.
I have red ones.
I think red means...
Pressure.
Is it getting good?
Nice!
We are collecting power now.
It's going well.
It looks like it's going well.
Then...
This one?
It's getting red.
It's not getting red.
Then isn't this one correct?
It's important, but the pattern is a little...
It's a little different.
Oh, the pattern.
For now, let's leave it as it is.
For now.
The others are red and...
Then this one?
Yeah, let's leave it as it is.
What are you doing?
There's one more can somewhere.
This one and the white power battery.
White?
What?
Red, red.
Everyone...
How did we all die?
Everyone died.
Everyone died!
This is difficult.
The pressure.
How did we all die?
There was an explosion in the middle.
I knew it.
I wanted to cry.
Oh my God.
Look at the crackle in the sky.
The crackle...
I think the pressure...
We are all dead.
Who is still alive?
That's Axel.
Where is Ahenya and K-san?
I can't hear them.
Are they dead too?
This game is too difficult!
Everyone died!
This game is too hard!
Axel!
Who is the second one?
I was the employee too!
Oh wait, sorry.
That's the only one that was the employee.
It's just the two of us!
That's right!
It's tough right now.
This is...
Scanner and...
You are...no?
You will cross eyes.
Yeah, I'm the bad guy.
But you guys are the bad guys.
OK,
employee.
Employee.
Just one task!
We have one!
One task!
Wait,
do we have to do everyone?
I'll go red.
OK, we'll go red.
Wait...
This is the power, right?
Oh it's on.
Wait...
We don't have any tasks here though.
Axel, there was...
The power!
Over here!
Over here, over here!
Check
the other section?
OK, OK.
Maybe we need a fuse like that?
I think that one is OK maybe.
OK...
OK,
I'll take the battery.
My battery!
What's that sound?
Is this where the tape cassette was?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Burning wish.
DMCA
What did you say, Super Chat?
Surely we get this one.
I am reading Super Chats.
I saw it earlier.
Sorry, I'm so tired you guys.
What?
Hey, Mr. Rabbit.
Mr. Rabbit.
Is everyone OK?
I love it!
Are you...
Why is everyone dead here?
Oh.
Why are they dead there?
I don't know, guys.
So, this one doesn't work.
I don't have anything.
You have to put everything in there.
You have C4?
I want to see it.
I want a C4.
This is C4, but I need some like switch to activate it.
Will this work?
Yes.
This is cool.
I don't have the thing for it.
You're not gonna take my weapon, right?
And kill me?
Nice to meet you.
No,
no, no.
Banzai, banzai, banzai.
Banzai, banzai.
OK, banzai, banzai.
Wait, wait.
You put it away.
Hestia!
Hestia is trying to kill me!
She was trying to kill me.
I'm innocent.
It was self defense.
Self defense.
2 minutes left.
We only have 2 minutes guys.
That's it.
I'll take this.
Oh empty?
Who killed me?
I think...
Daniel!
I believe in her!
He is running so...
He is running so desperately.
That's not true!
Wait,
ah?
I don't know who at all was...
Thank you for coming!
No, no, no.
Thank you to Mochi for raiding me.
Happy birthday Mochi!
Happy birthday to you!
That's not what you do on someone's birthday.
Don't do that on someone's birthday.
Don't do that.
The second thing that you did.
Yeah, that thing.
How do you learn to jork it?
Am I doing it right?
What the fuck are you?
She told her to try it out.
Oh, wait, am I...
Oh, I didn't try yet.
It's not easy!
Don't let Giddy fool you!
It's not easy.
It's so hard.
It's so hard!
Ok, Giddy, then don't leave us alone.
I'll look, I'll look, I'll look.
Look to your right.
Ok, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going, and stop!
Move to the right a little, look to the left a little bit, but slowly.
Left, slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly.
Stop!
Hey, I got the scanner too!
You got the scanner too?
Stop, stop, stop, and then look to your right again, a little bit, a little.
Very slow, very slow, to the left, to the left.
Slowly, slowly, you are very close.
Slowly, slowly, you are doing great.
Ok, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
It's too fast!
Let's go!
Ok,
let's go!
Let me do it again.
Sorry, let me do it again.
Oh!
I didn't even ready up.
There is two now, ok, ok.
Let me get the power.
Power.
Oh, the power!
I'll go find it.
Not here.
No.
The power, power.
What's that?
Oh, it's a C4, no?
I'm looking for weapons.
Wait, where would a good weapon be?
Maybe this way.
I'm feeling evil.
I need to bring a gun.
I am!
Ok.
Nice.
Pressure time.
No!
Wait,
do you want fish?
Yeah!
Here.
Mint!
Mint is the one!
No, you just killed...you just killed a lobster!
He had a gun.
Where did he drop the gun?
Where did the gun go?
Oh, I don't think it has any...
How did she kill me so fast?
Yeah,
you told me only me.
I knew it.
K-san killed me.
Yeah, she's imposter.
No,
it's K-san.
Not yet at all.
Wait!
There's something wrong...
I'm not feeling good.
Wait, he made me do it.
What the heck is that?
Did he grab them at one random?
Ehh... Ninja-san, no!
Ninja-san!
You're not an impostor!
Ehh... you killed me...
You're lying, you're lying.
I'm sorry, I'm an imposter.
I knew it, I knew it!
Look...
I saw you, you know, you were doing that thing where you open the window and get forgiven.
It worked.
It worked out.
It's gary!
It was kind of late for her to say that it was me.
She's...
Nice timing!
You're innocent to be an imposter.
No, I'm evil!
You're evil!
I can't be evil!
I'm sorry!
Let's make up.
Let's make up!
I hive!
High touch!
Everyone else...Everyone died by the pressure.
You just sprinted towards me with a knife!
I mean, what was I supposed to do?
That's a bad guy.
Hey guys, guys, back off!
Hey!
Stop!
Get away!
Did you stop when K-Fun acted?
Stop!
Did you stop when K-Fun said, please don't kill me?
Did you just say that?
No, you didn't.
I think I heard Henya from the distance.
That poor guy though.
Innocent!
The pressure, again?
Oh no.
Oh delivery!
I'll do delivery.
Delivery.
This is self-defense.
Oh, here is a...
This is a...for pressure.
Pressure!
No pressure!
Is there no delivery?
Package?
Hello!
Oh, Ota?
Oh, ok.
Oh my...
Ok, so just pressure.
Just pressure.
I don't trust.
Oh, you can trust me.
Ok, I trust you.
Oh...
I don't trust.
Wait, how did...how did he die?
He's so far...
How did she die?
Trap?
No?
It's not me.
It's self-defense.
What's happening?
Who's shooting?
Sniper?
Who's alive?
Who's...
Is
there anybody else?
Hello?
Me?
I don't know how to do this!
What?
Ok,
now I can do the pressure.
Wait, what's this?
Nothing.
Time for pressure!
Time for pressure.
I'm an employee!
I'm the employee of the month.
I'm the employee.
Ok, Gidi from beyond the grave, can you tell me how to do this?
Ok.
Oh it's empty.
Press the blue arrow.
Gidi!
Gidi, wake up!
Wake up!
Gidi!
It's a number guesser?
Like that?
Wait,
maybe over here?
Oh this one is ok.
This one is green.
Need all four?
We have 4 minutes guys!
Green.
It's ok!
Second one needs a blue.
What do you mean?
What do you mean it needs a blue?
This one is done, no?
Chat!
Gidi!
Stop being so lazy!
Only the wrong ones explode out.
What?
Before!
What did I do before?
Wait, I don't remember.
Wait!
So this one is wrong!
Wait, is there another one?
Look for other canister.
Other canister!
Ok, ok, ok.
I'll look around.
Take a blue!
Wait...
You think it's...
It's way too early for me to be doing this!
Take a blue.
Turn off the other one.
But it's working!
Why would I turn it off?
Orange storeroom.
There's none here, chat!
There's none here!
What's this do?
Turn off the other.
Ok.
What's this?
What's it do?
Off.
Ok, I take the blue.
Why blue?
But then won't it mess up that one?
Ok, blue.
I did it!
Ok, ok.
Wait, does this work?
Does this work?
Ah!
I don't get it!
I don't...
Oh my gosh!
One more minute!
No, no, no!
Red...wait, I have to turn this off.
Too much pressure!
I'll definitely die.
Ok, it's ok.
No!
Everyone, I'm sorry!
Everyone!
Can everyone hear me?
Everyone, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
Why did you kill me?
I'm an employee.
Yeah, if you were a good guy.
Oh, I thought you were...you shot me.
No, you shot me first!
Miscommunication.
Everyone, I'll shoot and then we forgive each other, ok?
After you forgive each other.
Did I shoot first?
Now we are friends again.
Is 10 minutes quite long?
I'll put it at 8 minutes.
Honestly, we didn't all die.
I think 10 minutes is pretty good.
It was just because Mint was by herself.
It felt like a long time.
Sorry.
No, it's ok.
Mint,
it's ok.
Let's go by your...
It looks like you are good at it.
Ok,
I'm an employee again.
Delivery!
It's green.
They saw me.
Is this delivery?
Look
at the box.
It has a green.
Where do I put it?
In here?
Delivery arrived!
The power.
Oh, we have to find the power, right?
Guys, I did a task properly for the first time.
Power, power, power, power.
Look at their little faces!
That was not happy.
I delivered.
We did it!
What was that?
Wait, that was so fast.
That was so fast!
Yippee!
We are getting better?
We are getting better.
Not me.
It was one power.
Let's go!
I'm an employee again.
Guys...
Scanner!
Scanner.
Brain not braining.
I'm losing power.
Haah...
Ready.
I'm ready.
OK.
Right, right, right, right.
Right, more right, more right.
Stop, stop, stop.
A little left, a little left.
A little left.
Stop!
A little right, a little right.
A little more.
OK, OK, OK.
Perfect, perfect.
A little more down, down.
Down, down, down, down, down, down, down, down.
Down, down.
Stop!
Ah, close!
A little right, a little right.
Right, up.
A little left, a little left, a little left.
Perfect.
Nice.
What should I do?
It's over.
Perfect.
Ah, so...
We did scan!
Nice.
Computers.
Guys, I'm gonna set up my waiting room for...
For the direct.
We'll set up the waiting room for the direct and the redirect into the direct.
I'm min-maxing streaming right now.
OK, after this stream we'll watch the direct and then I'll take a nap.
Who killed Henya?
Henya was the killer.
I stopped her.
Axel!
Axel?
It's Axel.
I'm trying to do this here.
I'm trying to do...
Yo, yo, you gotta trust me yo.
I don't know you!
Wait, wait.
Axel, Axel.
Look at me.
Look at your auntie in the eye.
Was it you or was it Henya?
Remember the video that we used to drink together?
What is mama da yo?
Remember the picture that you took with Oni bro?
Did you do it?
Where's the power?
Did you get it?
I don't know.
He's gotta look in his eye.
I'm not it.
You can kill me, but you're killing an innocent employee.
I'm innocent.
Yeah, we're innocent.
We're innocent.
I told you man.
I was innocent.
Go get a new battery.
He'll shoot.
Hey man, you need to calm down.
You need to calm down.
I don't know if you're ready for that.
That's a lot of responsibility.
I don't know if you're ready for that kind of weapon.
I don't have a battery!
Not this one.
The other one.
Ok, ok.
I got you.
I'm following.
I'm right behind you sir.
I'm right behind you.
I'm following.
I'm keeping...
I'm watching you.
I'm watching.
I'm gonna be behind you.
I didn't...
I was just making sure.
Ok, very good.
Nice!
Wait, how?
How did we win?
We're so good at the game though!
I got you.
Cinema.
You!
What are you?
What are you doing?
I will leave you.
This next...
Kisa has to leave soon, right?
So this next last game...
I'm gonna make this count everybody.
Last game!
Let's go!
Go hard mode!
Hard mode now.
We can do it!
Let's do it!
Employee.
Ok.
Pizushi!
Pizushi...
Pizushi.
Oh I think we have to make it.
Let's make it.
Pizushi.
Need rice.
Need rice?
Where is rice?
Where do I get the rice?
Rice.
Where?
What is this?
Is this for the rice?
Rice, rice, rice.
We gotta find it!
Pizushi!
We need rice!
Ok, maybe storage?
Oh wait, do we make this?
Black rice shrimp.
We need rice!
Rice, rice.
Rice, rice, rice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, rice.
Wait,
can you put that on there?
The container.
Ok.
Oh ok.
Nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh we need fish!
Fish!
Oh nice, nice.
Looks tasty.
Topping, topping, topping.
The school rice.
Oh wait, it's a good thing we got the right rice.
We got lucky.
Topping!
Topping, right?
It looks kind of leafy.
Right?
Probably.
Maybe in this area there is a topping.
Maybe.
Topping.
What kind of topping?
Oh, this computer?
What do I do here?
B04.
Me as a topping?
What are you talking about?
Don't say silly things you guys.
If I were an imposter I would sit here.
If I was an imposter, I would just wait here.
I'm looking for topping.
Looking for topping!
The what?
Yeah, I don't know what it is.
Oh, this?
Oh no!
Is that a shrimp?
It's a shrimp.
Oh no!
Well, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Yeah, it hit me.
You almost killed me.
It exploded.
It was an imposter.
No, don't be picky.
Don't be picky.
We have to find more rice maybe.
And then...
What's that?
This one, this one.
I got it.
It's empty.
We need the shrimp, we need the shrimp.
Why doesn't it work?
Container not clean.
Oh, what?
We need the rice.
Clean the box?
Okay.
How?
Clean it?
Oh, go to the washroom.
Washroom?
There is no washroom.
Oh wait.
Maybe...
Is there a sink?
A green area.
No, it's okay.
I think I just have to clean this.
Oh, here, here, here.
Where are you?
I have to clean the container.
Me too!
But I don't know where.
Oh I see, I see, I see.
Right here.
The washing machine.
I might be a little late for the direct guy, sorry.
We'll probably gonna die.
No, probably.
But we'll make pizushi.
Pizushi, pizushi.
Okay, now we can have rice.
We need shrimp.
Shrimp, shrimp, shrimp!
Pizushi, pizushi.
You have the other plant?
Nice, nice, nice.
Pizushi, pizushi.
Oh, shrimp, shrimp, shrimp.
It became shrimp.
It became shrimp, it became shrimp.
I did it!
Nice one, nice one!
It came to me!
The odd imposter!
This guy is lying.
Don't lie, everyone.
I don't know how to do this.
I have no idea too.
I think FBH and Sojo is imposter.
I think so.
Computer, yes?
I don't have power.
Power
Self -Defense Self-Defense!
Self-Defense!
He has a knife!
No, no, no
It's over!
You are not the one that has to do the math!
You were spreading them?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have to kill you though.
I have to kill you.
Stop!
I knew Gary would have just died from running.
Sojo also bad.
I knew you would have died just from running.
Wait, what's the sound?
No, no, no I knew you would have just died.
I want you to kill me.
I don't have power.
I don't know how to do this.
I have no idea.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Arigato!
Bye bye!
Let's play again!
Wait, how do I leave?
Ok guys!
Thank you!
Ok, I'm sorry.
I'm gonna run so fast and I'm gonna raid the next room.
Bye bye!
Raid into the wreck!